hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played yesterday
uh as the one of the games on hikaru
streaming was suggested to me by
subscriber dom
so thank you dom for suggesting such a
wonderful game and
in this game he carved with the white
pieces faces mata valerio mogrizzan
who is a candidate master from romania i
don't have a photo of the young
gentleman
but uh there is kind of one i don't know
if it's
the correct one but he was much younger
in that photo i was able to find online
so i'm using this
photo of the x-wing that he's using on
his chess.com profile
uh so without further ado let's check it
out as it's a
very very uh a very impressive game and
also features a similar
gambit to the evans gambit so i know how
much you guys you guys are like obsessed
with the evidence gambit so
i thought you guys would enjoy this one
so here e4 by hikaru
we have c5 uh evaluates for the sicilian
defense and here
the immediate b4 so the wing gambit is
on the board and i thought it
i thought it was really funny that um uh
mate has a
a a profile photo of an x-wing on
chess.com and here hikaru plays the wing
gambit against him but okay it's you
know it's always nice when things work
out so here
uh the pawn is gambited away and much
like you would do in the nemeziz gambit
so c captures on b4 and here a3
going for one further uh pawn uh grab
and this is the so-called martial
variation of the
uh wing gambit i almost said of the
x-wing gambit
and uh yeah sorry about that i have to
fix the sound a little bit so a3
trying to give up another pawn to get
more pieces into the game and hear
d5 by morgrizan and it's a very
principled thing to do
uh you just want to get your queen into
the game usually the problem with moves
like
the five characters is that once the
queen recaptures knight the c3
can immediately be used as a tempo to
kick away the queen however here the
presence of the b4 pawn prevents that so
d5
makes perfect sense uh e captures and d5
we have queen captures
and now knight to f3 you have to be
careful if you play a weird move then
queen e5
check and hikaru would lose that rook on
a1
so knight f3 of course he has to cover
the e5 square
and now e5 black is now ready to bring
the bishop into the game
and also the bishop can recapture if a
captures on b4 happens which is exactly
what hikaru does
now knight to c3 uh can be played on the
next move and here
bishop captures on b4 uh bishop to b2
fiance in the light square bishop
and now there's a double attack on the
e5 pawn so uh
valerio defends it uh so knight to c6
and now rook to a4 and this is a
very interesting move uh because in the
wing gambit you will very often see
rook to a4 move if black allows white to
open up the a file so this is a move
that will always be played
because it puts pressure on the bishop
and also the knight has to
uh guard the bishop and also the e5 pawn
however in this position it's
actually a terrible blunder so feel free
to pause the video
and find a winning move for black here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
this very nice winning idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen to e4 check
and it's uh really weird because it
aligns the queen with the rook here but
that's
exactly what you want to do and it
really doesn't matter what white plays
next
queen to e2 just runs into queen
captures on c2 and then black is dead
lost so
best is bishop to e2 but now just bishop
capture sanditu with
check you open a discovery towards
hikaru's rook and that's it queen
captures queen captures on a4
and black has more than enough to win
this game even after
uh white for example captures an e5
you're just going to play knight f6
castle
and that's it black is up the exchange
even up a pawn so nothing to worry about
for black here
so uh after this rook the a4 uh this was
definitely the winning idea queen to e4
check however
uh a mogadisan goes for b5 he wants to
kick away the rook from here
and this is actually something that
happens quite often when you play this
with white pieces because black very
rarely
encounters the wing gambit okay maybe in
blitz a bit more online
but it's a very uh it's not represented
all that well so here
b5 attacking the rook but now this is a
bad for black so feel free to pause the
video and find the movie car who played
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the
uh the beautiful uh exchange sacrifice
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
rook captures on b4 so removing one of
the defenders of the e5 pawn and then
uh knight the c3 will come into the game
with tempo and then the
pawn on b5 falls and so on so knight
captures on b4
only move and now knight to c3 now with
an attack on the queen and also the b5
pawn
uh of course you you have to be careful
not to blunder the queen for example
queen to c6 loses immediately to a move
like this
so queen to c5 is played and now bishop
captures on b5 with
check asking do you want to move the
king to f8 or do you want to block with
the bishop
you're not castling this game so either
way
so bishop the d7 was played hikaru
captured that king captures
and here uh well you could open up the
position would be for right away hikaru
decides to castle first
and now black needs to decide how how to
proceed here now do you try
bring knight f6 bring the rook into the
game and then maybe artificially castle
uh but that's that's a lot of moves so
here black tried f6
maybe he can also just hide the king
somewhere here but
hikaru immediately opens up the center
with the d4
and of course uh black doesn't want to
allow an attack so queen to d6
now hoping for d captures on e5 and
queen captures queen
if black can trade queens then it's
going to be playable
however here comes knight to b5 and
how does one come to a move like knight
to b5
well point is he car wants to play d
captures on e5 he
he wants it to happen without the black
queen
uh in interrupting this discovery so you
have to take away
the d6 and d5 squares from the black
queen so this is how hikaru does it the
knight to b5
now the black queen has only one square
to remain on the d file queen to d5 and
now of course c4 the queen is under
attack
and now the queen has to leave the uh
the d file so best
grab some material while while you're at
it so queen captures on c4
and now d captures on e5 now there's a
discovered
check we have queen back to d5 offering
a trade
and here hikaru goes queen to a4 now
offering uh
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
here so black needs to block
knight the c6 is played and now rook to
d1
and the black queen is trapped and here
you can easily resign with black
but we will show the rest of the game
because it features uh
a a most special moment so let's see how
the game continued knight
g to e7 and here queen to g for check by
hikaru there is always time to capture
the queen since
black can't really do anything about it
f5
and now comes rook captures on d5 with
chick
knight captures on d5 queen captures on
f5 with
check king to e8 and the now queen to e6
with
check and this is where the magic
happens knight to d
to e7 uh mogadism blocks the check and
now comes
knight the g5 knight c7 check also
is a very nice win it's actually a
checkmate in
11 but it's uh you know that knight g5
works just as well so here
rook the c8 not allowing knight to c7
sorry about the arrow and now comes
knight the f7
here knight to d4 attacking hikaru's
queen
and now uh feel free to pause the video
for the last time and find the forced
mating for for hikaru while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the amazing mate in four and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
uh it's knight deta uh knight f to d6
with check uh the point is uh you have
to be careful here if you capture the
knight you might even get
check made it so of course hikaru will
not fall for that he finds the
forced checkmating sequence knight after
d6 with
check now if you go here it's just going
to have seven checkmate
so king has to go to d8 but now knight's
the b7
check with this knight covering c7 the
king has to go back
king to e8 and now knight 5 to d6 with
check and now with this squirt covered
by this knight the king has no choice
but to go to f8 king to f8 is played and
now
queen to f7 a beautiful beautiful uh
checkmating sequence
uh so that's uh that's the game i want
to show you guys
like i said i know you guys are like
obsessed with the evans gambit so i
decided to show you the wings gambit
as we haven't had all that many games
regarding that and uh
really really was funny that uh mogadism
has a
profile photo of an x-wing and this game
featured the
uh the wing gambit but yeah
i will put a link to hikaru's stream in
the description below if you want to
watch the original of this game it's the
second game from the stream so you can
check that out as well
uh and yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this
and that you might uh
you know uh employ the uh wing gambit
you know if you if your opponent doesn't
allow you to go for the evidence you can
always go for the wing gambit if your
opponent plays the sicilian defense
uh so yeah i would like to thank donald
j henrik uh
frank combs peter radamovsky claudia van
wickler and
paolo pavel for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day